identificando los orígenes del nuevo
coronavirus en lo que alguna vez fue el
epicentro del brote en china expertos de
la organización mundial de la salud
visitaron el primer hospital en informar
sobre el kobe 19 un miembro del equipo
de la o ms publicó un tweet diciendo que
la primera reunión en el sitio fue
extremadamente importante y que hubo una
discusión abierta con los médicos y el
personal sobre los detalles de su
trabajo la misión de la ms en wuhan se
produce más de un año después de que la
ciudad de informará de su primera muerte
por coronavirus si bien nos ha divulgado
el itinerario exacto del viaje del
equipo se espera que visiten el
instituto de virología de buján y un
mercado de mariscos en el epicentro del
brote sin embargo no habrá ningún
contacto con la comunidad lado ms dice
que su equipo sobre el terreno seguirá
lo indicado por la ciencia y que todas
las hipótesis están sobre la mesa
mientras tanto los residentes de buján
esperan que la misión pueda arrojar
luces sobre como las autoridades de
china lograron controlar el virus
espero que puedan aprender de la
prevención de epidemias del gobierno
chino creo que nuestro gobierno ha hecho
un gran trabajo y espero que podamos
compartir estas medidas correctas con
otros países la investigación de la ms
se ha visto afectada por retrasos debido
a la preocupación por el acceso y las
acusaciones de eeuu de que china
inicialmente intentó ocultar el alcance
total del brote el ex presidente de eeuu
también acusó a los líderes de la ms de
estar coqueteando con beijing